The renowned writer and historian
William do ran,
one stated that quote,
a great civilization is not conquered
from without and so it has destroyed
itself from within.
Now,
those of you who've seen apocalypto may
remember that the movie opens with this
exact quote and it also really shooting
come as much of a surprise that the
mixture of Mel Gibson with a movie that
attempts to prove Duran statement
through to fictionalize decline of the
Mayan civilization,
was it the cause of some outbursts from
numerous scholars?
Stephen Ben's from the University of
Nebraska writes that quote legally
Gibson the madman.
We'd give him too much of a pass.
It will be to ignore us.
Unfortunately,
skilled participation in Hollywood
cinema as long history as a tool for
discrimination and oppression,
but most importantly a large chunk of
these critiques seem to culminate in a
climax of the movie with the coming of
the capital expanders and since the city
mayans are depicted as rotten and cruel
tracy and interprets this event as an
offensive and racist notion that my
people were brutal to one another long
before the arrival of Europeans and us.
They deserve that effect.
They needed rescue.
To be honest,
I had a hard time trying to find a
single academic article that wasn't an
overly negative about this movie,
so I figured it was about time for
someone to change that and to do so,
we need to start our analysis here.
It's a or Honda.
Immediately introduce the audience to
the first of the film's main themes and
values,
which is the hunter versus hunted
relationship.
Now,
there is a reason why this is important,
but I'll get back to that later.
The second theme reveals itself as
Jaeger par cuts of specific parts of the
animal and gifts them to his fellow
hunters.
Shortly thereafter,
they treat a part of the taper for some
fish.
God,
by now to try passing by giving and
sharing are shown to be integral parts
of the community's culture.
There existed conscious respect and
gratitude for the abundance of the
forest.
We just show them both non verbally,
not making use of literally every part
of the team.
Hello darkness,
my old friend and verbally.
My little later during the nighttime
Fiesta village elder tells the story of
the sad man who sat in the scrutiny,
never be quelled,
however much the world would give him.
Yeah know being at
a new gate,
take a book.
The theme of abundance has also extended
your parents respect for fertility.
Present in the community.
Flint sky speaks of having produced 10
children.
Do you ever pause his son?
His wife is pregnant with her second and
the kids run a muck in the village.
Blunted seems to be the odd one out as
he is unable to impregnate,
his wife is due to dissatisfaction of
her mother,
the situation which Mel Gibson then of
course utilize us to depict some 16th
century pranking
to register our next two themes,
family,
enjoy,
or a piece with no real hierarchy or
class system present.
The community seems to function as a
sort of big,
happy family.
In fact,
the first act of buck lipstick could
almost just as well be mistaken for a
feel good comedy about jolly mind's
kicking it into jungle.
However,
if things aren't all Hunky Dory,
as is evidenced in introduction of the
first opposite thing,
which is fear,
Jaeger pause,
brewery,
Budda,
encounter with the audit tripe,
they seem scared and running away from
something his father Flynn's skies
subsequently explains to him that fear
is a sickness.
Unfortunately Jaguar pause,
fear soon,
become very real as the city minds
approach the village and in contrast to
the jelly looking hunter and gatherers,
these mayans live grinman angry their
leaders.
Zero Wolf is seeing using human skulls
as part of his warriors outfit as sound
draws them near to the camp.
He orders them to split up and sneakily
make their way inside.
It is here that it becomes obvious that
these mines are on our hunts,
but instead of tape here,
fellow humans are to be their prey.
Firas spread like wildfire throughout
the villages.
Zero volts crew capture,
kill and rape their way for you to camp.
And as they make their way out,
the surviving children are left behind.
So at the beginning of the second act,
the themes of family love and fertility
are replaced by repressive authority and
hateful moral indecency.
And as soon made clear to violence and
pain are the determining factors of
strength in the community of the city,
Mayan Warriors,
the extend of the various contrasts
between your protagonists world and the
world of his captors becomes especially
apparent.
District group moves into dare part of
the jungle,
or rather what was one part of the
jungle,
the abundance fertility in all run
feeling of lightness of the jungle
village or a police by scarcity in
fertility and death.
One of the films most vital and powerful
scenes as the encounter with the girl.
The warriors have obviously given up any
hope of helping dose contaminated,
but what seems to be the plague as they
pushed the desperate little girl away,
she didn't seem to become possessed by
some higher power,
which then prophesizes the coming of the
Spaniards and the end of the Mayan
civilization.
Yes.
According to William Doran,
the sign of a civilization is the client
expresses itself and moral.
The gay that's a group enters the city.
It has shown that the sense of community
and family has been replaced here by a
lack of care for the weekend to old and
slavery,
theft,
and of course the dehumanization of the
human body depicted in the sacrifices to
the gods.
Again,
fear and violent at 40 are shown to be
the determining factors of the society.
On of that,
their leaders are conscious of this and
the abuser through dare advantage to
rule and some theater people as is
evidenced by the preexisting knowledge
of the coming solar eclipse,
so it makes the scape the board has set
and the stakes are clear besides being a
personal struggle of life and death both
for January as well as his trapped wife
and son to chase metaphorically also
signifies a struggle between the before
mentioned opposite themes and values.
Love versus hey,
abundance versus scarcity,
freedom versus captivity,
authority 40 versus family,
the hunter versus hunted and of course
courage versus fear,
and it is exactly in this last aspect in
which Jaeger par is lacking.
After taking a leap of faith,
he finally realized this and the science
let go of his fear depicted in a scene
in which he metaphorically embodies the
symbolism of the Jaguar,
which to some stands for the power to
face one's fierce in front one's
enemies.
It's at that point it stops being the
hunted and retakes,
the role of the hunter thank wishing his
adversaries,
one by one
users took a hell of a hit and most
obvious sign of this change in roles of
course has shown fruit to death with
zero wolf by use of the TPO track.
Jennifer
fraud doesn't retake this role for a
long as a chase ends on the beach and
we're back at that controversial climax
and we finally meet the ultimate hunters
or to become the bringers of unspeakable
amounts of death.
Of course,
as you might've noticed,
I don't much agree on a degree of
controversy.
Apply to Apocalypto as a whole,
as I believe that I've shown a story to
me is not at all about justifying or
sweet talking European colonialism in
the Americas,
but rather about more universal themes
and real life cultural tendencies.
Mel Gibson as you several aspects of the
Mayan civilization to depict the sort of
a historical summary of its people's
rise and fall,
you can even argue that the movie really
isn't all that much about the Mayans at
all as it Gibson himself as stated that
he sees that Buck Lipo is more of an
allegory for modern day America with
many of the same struggles playing a
role in today's society.
I would go as far as stating that
apocalypto stories even more universal
than that and can be seen as a general
visualization of William Durant's
opening.
Quote Duran,
of course,
was speaking of the fall of the Roman
civilization,
but Gibson being Gibson left some direct
references to that sign within the story
of Jaguar as well as another character
or shown seven wounded in the right side
of the abdomen.
This combined with the fact that the
group is being marched off to be
sacrificed and mistakenly brings to
memory one of Gibson's other
protagonists
and right before this is all about to go
down.
Blumkin's mother in law has a brief
Maria moment straight out of the passion
of the Christ.
So in the end,
I believe there's far more substance to
apocalypse,
so dan just a chase scene and a quote
unquote racist message.
It's an action movie of Great
Cinematography and one of the best chase
sequences in Hollywood cinema's history
most,
but in its score,
it remains deeply relevant story about a
universal moral struggle in the cycle of
rise and fall and hunter and hunted,
and although the movie of course the
pics,
the apocalypse or the beginning of the
end for the Mayan civilization,
it also,
and perhaps more importantly,
leaves us with a message of hope to
stick to our morals,
to face the future and to have the
courage to start it all over.
All right guys.
That's the end of our analysis for
apocalypto.
I hope you enjoyed a.
had a bit of a hard time tackling this
video because there are basically you
were in any articles that agree with my
view of the movie.
Anyways.
What did you think of apocalypse?
So I would love to hear your thoughts on
it in the comment section down below.
As always,
if you like what we do and what more or
just feel like helping us out a bit,
check out our patrion pitch and or share
this video with the rest of the world.
I want to thank you again for watching.
Happy New Year and I hope to see you all
again in 2017.